welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss i'm here with mt
and we are talking about episode two of
the fountain of the winter soldier this
is a q a we're gonna take all your
biggest questions
we're gonna talk about who the real
villain of this show might
be oh we've gone down this rabbit hole
before with marvel shows let's hope we
don't fall flat on our face again
how are you doing i'm doing great how
you doing eric oh i'm doing good i'm a
little nervous
uh i'm just trying to you know manage my
expectations a bit
i don't think the real villain's
mephisto i'm getting that out of the way
right now
no it's i'm apisto though who knows
maybe film theory will cut this out of
context and put it in a supercut to make
fun of me in a video
we'll see um anywho let's take our first
question
who do you think is the true villain of
this show
because i feel like the flag smashers
are gonna end up being the good guys
throughout her delivering vaccines
this john walker guy he's suspect i
don't like him
and zemo i feel like he could surprise
us all that cam you at the end like he's
still locked up like what is he gonna do
oh give me butterflies your question
gives me butterflies
um i agree with you um pretty much on
all of that i don't think
the flag smashers are being called robin
hood i think they're going to be
anti-hero kind of tragic figures
uh freedom fighters in a way just kind
of like the way aaron kellerman's
character was in solo a star wars story
isn't this nest you you're worried about
the cloud writers and by the end of that
movie you're like
oh they're actually going to be part of
the rebel alliance oh
isn't that nice they aren't actually
villains but yeah so empty and i were
talking about this uh before
i think the power broker and or
thaddeus ross that's where my money is
on i think
daddy frost is gonna be part of black
widow i think he's going to be kind of a
governmental
bad uh tied in with some other power
broker either ross himself
or someone else that we know from marvel
maybe zola
zola is a bit crazy i'll admit um but uh
power broker might just be a new figure
i mean it could be a whole bunch they
might merge it with other characters
like
in addition to zola there's like modoc
out there you know there's justin hammer
who's out there
uh there's the leader yes you know from
the first hulk movie he's still out
there and the leader in the comics is
deeply tied in with aim advanced idea
mechanics uh
uh but that's in the intelligentsia you
know there's a whole like
plot there um but who do you think
i mean yeah i'm gonna have to go with
the power broker and
because i i honestly believe that the
power broker is supplying
power to anyone who wants to buy it
whether it be the us government whether
it be the flagsmasters or whoever
so this mysterious murderous power
broker
uh might be the this villain but if i
were to just completely ballpark it
like something wild i think that it
could potentially
we could maybe possibly see
killian again from iron man 3 because he
was doing
um you know body manipulation um
enhancement stuff with the extremist
project
so there i mean but he went boom boom he
did go boom boom he explained but he did
have
extremists in him so like it could
potentially just be like oh
and his body i don't know he was fine
and now he's starting
star fish rules like if one exactly
starfish survives
one piece it turns into an exactly so
like we could see killing again but like
that's just outrageous and
that's probably not going to happen but
also another idea that popped into my
brain a couple days ago
is white vision we don't know where
white vision
is oh and the reason why i bring this up
is because the power the second power
broker in the comics looks like this
pale
like he has no identity so like no one
really knows who he is so he could
literally be adapted into anyone but he
is this pale looking man so like
what if white vision left and decided to
become his own person
and kind of like evil but like that's
that's out there that's just another
wild theory
but i like the idea of white vision i
don't expect paul betty to come back in
this show but
it does you did just link two kind of
interesting questions in a way that
makes me very excited i don't need a
bluetooth now after hearing
that theory that's what all the ladies
uh
will say it's like hey mt yeah like you
uh get me real excited with these uh
marvel theories
um no one says that um at all but no
i'll say it yeah i don't think uh i
don't
white vision seemed to be more on a
noble quest i mean that [ __ ] the thesis
analogy did a number it's true
he could be out building ships somewhere
he's like i don't know what he meant but
i have to
and someone's like you broke down my
ship he's like yes but i built a new
ship it's the same thing
and they're like what is this a freaking
lego movie build my [ __ ] back he's like
but it would be the same
just build it back android no like sam
goes back to see his sister in like a
vision just working on her [ __ ]
like the his parents ship it's like oh i
thought this would seem pretty old i
just thought i'd just make a new one
but before we continue thank you to blue
blocks for sponsoring this video
look no matter how hard you try it's
hard to get your bedroom 100 dark at
night
lights always coming in through the
curtains there are those little lights
on your electronic devices your power
strip the the ghost who's shining the
mag light in your eyes you know all that
paranormal light in your room makes it
harder to fall asleep and harder to stay
asleep
well the blue blocks remedy sleep mask
is the solution it creates
100 darkness and is super comfortable
it's got these adjustable eye cups for
the perfect fit and it works whether you
sleep on your belly or your side or your
back and you can
fully open your eyes with it on oh my
god oh my god oh my god i'm in the
sunken place there will never be any
light again this is actually what i want
i can finally sleep now
i've used other sleep masks before they
were never as comfortable or as
effective as the blue blocks remedy
sleep mask whether you're looking to
improve your sleep or help with
meditation or get some rest while
traveling
these masks are awesome just go to
blueblocks.com
new rockstars or click that link below
to get 20 off your remedy sleep masks
today
my code is automatically applied for
that 20 off so all you need to do is
click the link below
to get the best sleep possible right now
just grab yourself a blue blocks remedy
sleep mask just go to b
l u b l o x dot com new rockstars or
click the link below to get 20
off your order code automatically apply
to check out um let's take another
question here do we think that somehow
the jerk
thaddeus ross is involved with either
the power broker or he is the power
broker or he's involved with the grc
because i think he's super obsessed with
super soldier serum
so i thought there's a good chance he
could want the flax masters to work for
him
so just do we think that he is involved
somehow especially because he's a
terrible person
thank you so much um yeah uh yeah liz i
think you're
you're thinking on the same wavelengths
we are that thaddeus thunderbolt ross is
involved and i think that grc sounds
just like the government i mean he's
secretary of state
which is uh involved with like
international relations right and
international diplomacy
often secretary of state is a position
that can pretty much be interchangeable
with like you in
u.n secretary um they often speak at the
eu and they're
often involved with different
international alliances and ross
could totally step into that position as
head of the grc
um i i think that's probably where he is
now um
and yeah if uh i think there might be i
don't know if they're gonna call it the
thunderbolts
but i think he's gonna be involved in
putting together his own super soldier
team to like replace the avengers that's
gonna be more or less
what the thunderbolts was yeah no yeah i
i don't know
like i definitely think that he's
involved i don't know if he's the power
broker himself
but he's a he's definitely a big
contender for that potential role
um so yeah i don't know we'll see how he
comes into play but he's definitely
going to come into play
to some degree because he's in the
credits i mean what i really want to
happen
is like uh a thaddeus ross and zola
alliance that's been going on behind the
scenes for a while that'd be great
like if they just have a scene where you
know ross uh
swirls his uh liquor and he sits down
and then like zola's face just pops up
on skype or something like that
that that's my mephisto moment for this
show right that's all i want but
just like or just a green glow on
william hurt's face and i'll know it's
right green green is the new red baby
yeah i mean like i definitely do think
that like i don't know i'm i'm of the
belief that we will
get some type of zola something this
season um
so we will we'll see what happens don't
stop believing in
the power of belief just keep clapping i
believe in fairies i believe in zola
zola train
zola will die if you stop believing in
seriously everyone believe right now
let's take another question i was
wondering if you think that
the flag smashers are going to have any
relation to red skull
because like in the comics red skull
funds the flag smashers and like right
now
they both have red faces on but like
also in the first captain america movie
uh the red skull says i have seen the
future
there are no flags no flags
a rite of passage for captain america's
now
yeah that quote has come back a lot when
it comes to the flag smashers
um i've seen the future and there are no
flags now
it's hard to do retroactive easter eggs
like that right because then it would
say
so the writers you know back in 2010
when they were writing
captain america the first avenger that
they had in mind that in 2020
uh they would be shooting this show
where there would be a militant group
called the flag smashers and that i
don't think they knew the events of
end game or infinity war or even thanos
back when they were working on that
first cap film so if they could think
that far ahead
here's what i'll say though is i think
there are some um
philosophical parallels between what red
skull ultimately wanted and what the
flag smashers wanted and that they
wanted
to see a world united however
red skull was a fascist he wanted to
dominate it with hydra
um whereas the flag smashers are more
pacifists anarchists i don't know if
they're pacifist that's not the right
word for it but they are anarchists
i don't think they want any kind of
government control they just want people
to live peacefully
and in the blip people were just too
depressed to wage war against each other
uh i don't think red skull would like a
blip world i think red skull would be
like
the blip has gone good half the avengers
are gone let me dominate it with my army
yeah
you know so i i don't see too much of a
link between red skull and the flag
smashers other than
those words yeah i'll have to yeah i 100
agree like you hit the nail on the head
with the um
comparing their ideologies and yeah i
just think that
the fl i really just don't believe that
the flag smashers would even like red
skull to be get to be honest
yeah they'd hate them yeah like they
would be oh so like a nazi
a guy who's worse than like now unless
he
is like the power broker and he kind of
helped them you know but
we gotta ask where he is right now red
skull it sounds like was liberated from
his servitude once the
soul stone was taken from born here now
uh
it seems like the soul stone was put
back right so does that mean he has to
continue working there
or is it just guarded by someone else is
it a rotating position
um but uh i don't imagine red skull
seems like more like a cosmic figure in
the mcu now he might show up in a
guardians of the galaxy movie or a thor
movie
before he would show up in a really
grounded spy movie
or spice series see i don't know see
with the red skull for me i honestly
think that they're gonna bring them back
because there there has to be because
like we only got him really for
for one movie i mean we sort of got him
in infinity war and end game but like
the red skull character is such a big
captain america villain and just a big
um marvel villain in general and so we
haven't really seen him
on earth in the modern day so i think
that somehow
um he will find his way back to earth
but that's just me i don't know if he's
the i don't think he's the power broker
at all
but like i think he might find his way
back to earth but that's just me
but great question yes uh let's continue
to take some
hi me again you guys obsessed with you i
thought battlestar was an alias for
bucky wasn't i
looked it up a little bit and i was very
interested in knowing more about it
um someone uh tell me i'm not crazy
tell me i'm not wrong i mean if it were
if it were a different alias than
battlestar i would agree with you
um because i think battlestar is just
what his name is in the comics and i
think
bucky was just like oh god no not these
wannabe avengers i don't wanna hang out
with these guys
but if he had said like oh my name my
code name is
uh is like freight car or something like
that or like rusted or something in
one of his something that was like oh is
that your bucky in some other way
you know uh or my uh code name is like
uh
bucharest or something you know um but
just battle star
battlestar good you know it's just kind
of like a cheesy 80s name it was chosen
because these guys were like wrestlers
they were bold urban commandos
who were trying to be like cap wannabes
in the 80s
and so that's just kind of the names it
sounds like a american gladiator's name
right and that's why
it's like marvel comics is trying to
kind of parody that of these guys think
they're real-life superheroes
so i think that's what uh bucky was
cringing to that whole idea of like oh
these guys who want to
you know hang with the big boys no i'm
not hanging
i mean i don't know because like that i
mean that that is highly likely because
like
bucky's just like look at these young
young bloods thinking that could be like
me and steve
forget them um but i honestly i think
that there might be something with that
battle star name connected to bucky's
past
so that means now people are gonna tweet
me in three weeks being like hey your
battle star theory was wrong
like i never said that you just
spitballed and i think i did yeah he's
an inside marvel but like
yes um i don't i don't know but like
what we
we have yet to see but i don't believe
battlestar is connected
with bucky in the past though i could be
wrong but i'm pretty sure
that battle starts just lamar hoskins um
title yeah to me it seems like i mean
all i read for maybe it's because i grew
up with older siblings who wanted to get
out of the car when i hopped in it
on things so it was kind of just like no
no i don't want to go see um freaking
thumbelina with eric today i want to go
see
apollo 13. i'm like little six-year-old
me like no i want to see thumbelina
no and then even i'm watching them
bullying and being like this movie kind
of sucks
what do you think about bucky
calling himself white wolf
because in the comics he's
white wolf later so it's pretty cool
actually
um what do you think about that i think
it was a reference to
the black panther post credit scene
where those wakandan kids run away they
go white wolf white wolf and you see it
in the uh
in the subtitles of that scene uh he got
that nickname from the wakanda yes
uh and i think it was a reference to the
white wolf character
um to hunter who's kind of leading the
wakandan secret police
and he's kind of a badass he was like
this uh this white kid whose parents
and him were flying over the plane went
down and what kind of what kind of kind
of adopted him and then
at first the wakandan people were like
and then they ended up accepting him and
he was super loyal to t'challa
but i am interested to know what that
title meant to the mcu wakandans exactly
was it just a kid's nickname for him or
did he actually work
for uh shuri and fort t'challa during
his time there
helping them on missions did he help
them with security at the beginning of
infinity war it seemed like he was still
wearing his um
relaxation robes and then they gave him
the black vibrating alarm so
i'm wondering how much time he had to go
on missions with them
and then he and t'challa dusted at the
end of infinity war so
yeah i'm wondering what he did during
that time yeah i i think that honestly
uh bucky was just chilling like he he's
i think he mentioned
in episode one that like his only time
where he got to rest was in wakanda
and so he was just relaxing and like
just not
being in a war for what the for once in
his life
and uh once uh t'challa and um okoye i
believe
uh gave him the arm and infinity war
it's like he was immediately like
where's the fight because you wouldn't
give me this arm if there wasn't a fight
coming so
where is it so yeah right um
that's that's just what i think about
that no i think that's a good point
uh let's take another question do you
think the new captain america already
has
the superhero serum yeah or they're
gonna
put it in him later and then he's gonna
turn evil
because of that oh kylie blonsky how he
lost his mind
yeah that's an interesting thought i
think he already has it
because the fact that he's so hush-hush
about his physiology when that good
morning america
uh producer is asking about it and then
he um
you see that footage of him like ripped
when he's uh doing the
the box scene just like we saw cap going
at the punching bag and avengers
and then he must have only had that
shield for like what 48 hours
uh when he was flinging it around like i
don't know how much time passed over the
course of episode one
it seemed like it was like three or four
days yeah uh where
where sam handed over the shield and
then he went back to louisiana to hang
out with his sister
and probably another day passed when
they scheduled that bank loan
appointment
and then right later that day uh i mean
it would have taken people time to
travel around as well because walking
towards goes from
tunisia to switzerland uh so that he can
make that call
but ultimately it would like uh
john walker would not have had that much
time with that shield to get good at it
and to blink it around like that
you need a lot of strength yeah um it
does have some like aerodynamic
qualities to it
like there's like magnetic qualities to
it that also could have been faked that
could have been cgi
but we saw him on that um truck he was
pretty good with it yeah pretty good he
was able to catch
lamar hoskins with it so yeah i think he
already has it oh yeah he definitely has
some type of powers
in him um i don't know if um
he's like if he has super soldier serum
in him but like
he's empowered in some way um and i
think that it's probably in a sketchy
way
because like you know with him being
real you know hush-hush about what was
going on in mit and all that stuff
um but yeah i i don't know exactly
i think that maybe he might be in a
quest for more power
um throughout the as the series goes on
because of the weight of the
responsibility of the mantle
um but you know i definitely do think
that he has some type of powers now
so we'll see how that goes agreed let's
take one more question here
since good morning america is now in the
mcu and eric was on good morning america
does that mean that eric is now in the
mcu yes yes is now mcu canada i'm glad
you asked that because i was gonna bring
it up
eric my boy was on good morning america
the other day and good morning america
was an episode
i literally had that exact same thought
as they came up i was like yo
it's eric's people
i mean yeah i i guess you're right um
sure i'll take it i'll take it i would
hope that i'm not mc cannon just so i
can get a better role later
like you don't have to extend it that
far i mean look these movies
you can do these this kind of tommy
westfall extended connection of like
wait so if like star wars exist in the
mcu
and if uh you know troubleman exists in
the mcu like all these other references
to the all the songs they reference of
point break exists
that means that like uh keanu reeves
exists in the mcu so if counter reeves
ever plays a role
in the emcu are they going to get
confused um you know
i mean if you think about this tony
stark said lebowski and he fought
freaking jeff bridges
jeff bridges perfect example perfect
example
so so so but hey teens yeah i will
take that to the bank i was on the fact
that it was same week
right or like you know uh a week before
a gma
uh good well congrats on gma for getting
mcu canonized
for sure and uh i am in the mcu baby
yes
i mean did it count when they said but
why hexagons
in one division i think i counted that
as being
i think so too we had just put out a
thumbnail saying what's with the hexagon
they were watching it that's exactly why
how they got their blackboard up he's
like what is eric saying and then just
take
this write down everything you say on
the whiteboard
um well that's all we have time for we
have a lot we want to get through today
we have a suicide squad
trailer that i got to break down uh and
this episode of falcon winter soldier
that i'm going to break down all the
easter eggs of so we want to thank you
all for sending your questions um
and be sure to follow mt at
mastertainment follow me at ea vase get
your hands on this new
latest obsession shirt uh i should be
wearing it i just haven't had time to
put it on but here it is and it's got a
bunch of great easter eggs it's inspired
by the end credits of this series it's
really cool
and when you get it you get you can
unlock the added option to
write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of our inside
marvel after shows
so yeah thank you guys so much for
joining us uh stay tuned
for this and all the other shows we have
a new episode of fitness origins coming
out on sunday that's going to be crazy
but we love you guys and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you